[موسيقى]
إذا قمت باستبدال الكمبيوتر المحمول الخاص بك خلال
الإجازات ، فكر مليًا قبل التخلص
من الجهاز القديم ، فقد تكون هناك صور قديمة
لألعاب الموسيقى والملفات التي قد
ترغب في حفظها على موقع الويب الذي تمت مراجعته مؤخرًا ،
ونظر في الخطوات التي يجب اتخاذها لإنقاذ
أي شيء  تريد الحفظ قبل
التخلص من جهاز كمبيوتر محمول قديم ، حدد أولاً
المكان الذي تريد حفظ المحتوى فيه
google drive onedrive و dropbox
كلها خيارات إذا كنت تفضل عدم
إزعاج التخزين الفعلي اعتمادًا على
مقدار التخزين الذي تحتاجه قد تضطر
إلى دفعه  اشتراك شهري في
الخدمات أو يمكنك الحصول على
محرك أقراص ثابت للتخزين الخارجي ، يمكنك العثور عليه مقابل
حوالي خمسين دولارًا ، وبمرور
الوقت ستكلفك أقل من
اشتراك التخزين بمجرد أن يكون لديك جميع
هذه الملفات احتياطيًا التي تريدها
لمسح جهاز الكمبيوتر الخاص بك نظيفًا ، ابحث عن
الوظيفة الموجودة على الكمبيوتر والتي تتيح لك
إجراء إعادة تعيين ثابت للتخلص من البيانات الموجودة
على الجهاز للنوافذ التي يمكنك كتابتها في
إعادة التعيين في ميزة البحث في
المهمة  شريط لبدء العملية وبعد الانتهاء
من كل ذلك ، سترغب في
تحديد ما يجب القيام به مع الكمبيوتر المحمول ،
يمكنك إعادة تدويره من خلال أفضل شراء أو
الشركة المصنعة للجهاز أو التفكير في
التبرع به ، فهناك عدد من
المنظمات التي توفر
الطلاب والأسر المعرضين للخطر الذين لديهم
كمبيوتر محمول يعمل